I recommend we remove all magic even
memories of magic to be safe
hey grandpappy we have a question for
you when you wiped
Ana's mind clean of magic did you
accidentally prevent her from developing
powers of her own we mean if Elsa has
powers why wouldn't her sister have any
it just doesn't add up
Ana's made it clear that she doesn't
need powers to save the day
excuse me I climb to the North Mountain
survived a frozen heart and saved you
from my ex-boyfriend and I did it all
without powers so but powers wouldn't
hurt now would they Elsa is about to go
up against the biggest threat arendelle
has ever faced so if you've been hiding
on his powers all along it's time to
speak up frozen fans everywhere would
jump for joy if Anna got some powers of
her own there are so many low-key hints
pointing to Princess Anna being up the
magical variety and we're about to dig
them up watch until the end to find out
which sister is the strongest Elsa or
Anna frozen to is hitting the big screen
on November 22nd 2019 and Disney have
given fans the lowdown on what to expect
from the sequel we know that Elsa is
hearing a strange voice and that
something big and bad is coming for
arendelle we now says people are running
for the hills literally and grandpappy
believes that the only way to save
arendelle is for Elsa to locate whoever
or whatever is calling out to her Elsa
and the gang are about to journey north
to the enchanted lands and into the
unknown and it's going to be epic
but before agreeing to let her sister
and friends tag along Elsa was
determined to go on the journey alone
I'm going with you Anna
and for obvious reasons - Elsa thinks
that she should go north alone because
well she's the only one with powers and
things can get dangerous her stuff can I
borrow your wagon and Sven I'm not very
comfortable with the idea of that once
again Elsa wants to do everything on her
own but that's just not how it works and
whether she wants to admit it or not she
needs honor by her side because on it
brings a lot to the table and she's not
about to let her sister forget it when
anna volunteers to accompany Elsa Elsa
immediately says no she tells onna that
she has powers to defend herself whereas
honor does not and that's when Anna's
fiery nature kicks in she points out
that she's climbed the North Mountain
survived a frozen heart and saved Elsa
from Hans so basically she can take care
of herself the gang has a much better
chance of saving arendelle if they work
as a team but will it be enough or will
Anna need some powers of her own to save
the day
ever since frozen came out the ants have
wondered if Anna has powers too although
none of them appeared in the first film
a few key hints were dropped like when
Grandpa be cured young Ghana's frozen
head I recommend we remove all magic
even memories of magic so what if Anna
did have powers but they hadn't kicked
in yet
good grandpappy have accidentally
repressed Ana's magical abilities are
they laying dormant in the darkest
corners of her mind and sure seemed to
think so
I also showed us firsthand how difficult
it can be to control new powers so what
if Anna is the one responsible for the
pink flames we see in the trailers these
flames are sporadic and out of control
so it would make sense that they belong
to honest and she doesn't know how to
use them in the first place but what
would cause honest hours to suddenly
appear well we think it has everything
to do with on a now so walking into the
fog and crossing over into the enchanted
lands this magical barrier could work as
a catalyst for Ana's powers we all know
that Elsa has ice powers in the bag she
often wears the color blue
I see blonde hair and is born on the
winter solstice on on the other hand
often wear summery colors like green and
fuchsia pink
she has auburn hair and is born on the
summer solstice this can't be a
coincidence
all these little hints point to onna
having fiery powers of her own these two
sisters are polar opposites and they can
cancel each other out and that's why
it's so crucial for Ana's powers to
appear in frozen to in the official
frozen trailer grand pabbie tells onna
that Elsa needs her because magic can be
very alluring so basically if Elsa isn't
careful she can lose herself to power
and that's why Anna is so important
she's the only one who can talk Elsa
down and if need be she might be the
only one who can take Elsa on if also
becomes power-hungry or possessed by
whoever is calling out to her Anna will
be arendelle's last hope
but since Elsa is so powerful only
someone with opposing abilities would be
able to go up against her so if anna has
fire powers she could use them to melt
whatever ice Elsa throws her way but
hopefully it won't come to that
after all anna has a way with words and
a huge heart so maybe she could help
Elsa walk a straight path using words
alone if anna has the ability to control
fire she would be evenly matched with
Elsa but since anna hasn't mastered her
abilities yet Elsa would have the upper
hand but once onit learns to control her
powers she'll be just as powerful as
Elsa do you think Anna has powers sound
off in the comments and that's a wrap
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up we'll catch you next time on the
things thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]